yeah hello everyone thanks so much for
showing up even um on the last day in
the afternoon really appreciate it
um yeah so we want to present you today
our
machine learning project that we did at
idialo where we clustered offers
with the transformer approach
um
maybe before we get started a quick show
of hands who here in the room is
familiar with neural networks and
general architectures of neural networks
can you raise your hand
well okay so pretty much everyone and
who is familiar with the transformer
architecture
okay so around 5050 so
yeah the bad news is
this is not a deep dive into
transformers so you probably won't learn
that much about transformers themselves
in this talk
but the good news is that there's
amazing material out there so
for example the illustrator transformer
probably most of you or some of you have
read this already so um yeah but this
talk um is not really directed at at
going or
deep diving into transformers
uh yeah so uh we are sebastian over here
and
um i'm christopher we are both engineers
and in the central machine learning team
at idialo and we are eight people now
and we kind of consult other product
areas on machine learning projects
and we also try to enable them so to
to kind of like make their machine
learning iterations faster
and
basically
go in the platform direction so we kind
of do both streams
uh yeah maybe just a few facts around
idialo briefly so
we've been around for over 20 years
and
active and over in six different
countries there are over 900 people by
now working for idialo
maybe on the right hand side um quite
interestingly uh their idialo has
contracts with over 50 000 shops um so
so we get basically offered data from
over 50 000 merchants
and and this leads then to
over 330 million of product offers that
we have
available
and currently our product catalog has
around 2 million products this is kind
of important for the talk that's why i
can mention these numbers a little bit
um yeah that's that's it about idialo
and i don't know
if any of you have used idio before but
for example if you
idiot is a price comparison probably i
should have mentioned that
sorry
so for example if you look for adidas
sneakers right um these these would be
your search results and you can see
yeah various different
adidas summer products and for example
if i click on the one on the top left
then you can see there we list all the
offers that we have for that product
available from all those shops
so
um
you can
sort of can i actually
you see my cursor yeah
so actually you can see this is for
example one offer for this um for the
shoe then there's the second offer here
and the third offer we just kind of list
all these offers for this product
and
in this case it's it's ranked by by
price but there are other dimensions
that you can sort your your data for for
example also proximity to where you live
so we also have a lot of local inventory
so it also allows a lot of local shops
to list their products and
and compete against marketplaces like
amazon and ebay which we also have
um
so yeah um this is basically what what
idialo at its core looks like um
and you can also see that one of the
the prominent attributes of an offer is
this um
offer title so here it would be adidas
zamba hainshu
and then yeah
you can see that that basically all the
offers have a unique title and there are
other attributes that we have for these
offers um
[Music]
yes and this might be important for
later on
um
we do have a problem however that the
vast majority of offers are not mapped
to our product catalog and we are
talking
of hundreds of millions of offers and
that we are simply not able to to kind
of like link to the products in our
catalog
and um
yes and this um
of course this is not ideal so it
it could be that a lot of these offers
actually belong to products in our
product catalog but we simply
we can't map them
and and and the other case would be that
we actually have a lot of products not
available in our product catalog that
are however represented in in all of
these hundreds of millions of offers
um and and this is kind of like where
this um project um originated from the
idea if
if we look at at kind of like our we
call it open catalog so all these offers
we cannot map to the product catalog and
it would be awesome if we had some sort
of system where we could cluster these
offers so here you see for example three
different types of sneakers and it would
just be great we had some um way to to
kind of like identify these
clusters ie products
um
and we had some initiatives in the past
um where basically you do some id
matching um and and that works to some
extent so for example here you have one
attribute of offers which is this e-a-n
this is like a european article number
it's kind of like an id number and um
the problem there is that this is not or
this is only available for around 50 of
our open catalog offers and and and so
yeah but quite often you can't make the
connections like you see here at the top
and cluster b because it's simply not
available
and we also have quite a lot of
occurrences where this number is not
being updated properly especially for
product variants of different colors of
the essentially the same product um but
um yeah then this this ein can be wrong
for example like you see here
um so yeah and matching works to some
degree and we will look at some some
some actual numbers in a bit
and so kind of the idea was to to use
machine learning on text attributes and
the first iteration to make this
clustering a bit smarter
and and so we would use various text
features and like the title
like color we have other other
attributes available and also the the
the id number and we would just try
various um
machine learning approaches to to make
this clustering a bit smarter
this is the core idea and the core
motivation
of what we try to tackle
um so yeah we tried various machine
learning approaches
and i would like to
show you the results straight away so
i'm going to show you the results for
various things that we tried out
and
talk a little bit about um give you some
some some some rough uh yeah some
details on each of the approaches but we
will then do a deep dive afterwards and
the best performing approach which is
which is this transformer based approach
just as an fyi um so let's have a look
at the results the short disclaimer all
of these results are on a limited data
set so around 10 000 products all from
the shoe category and
on average i think there were 17 offers
per product and so it's not a huge data
set but it was kind of the biggest data
set for which we have all of these
numbers available for the different
approaches the final models that we
productionized and are trained on on
much more data
um yes and
these would be the results here you can
see on the on the vertical axis on the
left you can see the f 0.5 score
um
so this is a score that ranks i can
never see my cursor here myself so
um this is a yeah this is a score that
lies between zero and one and it's um
it's kind of like weighted towards
precision so usually f score is the
harmonic mean of precision and recall
and we put like a higher weight on
precision because it was deemed more
important for our project to be precise
um
yes and then on the horizontal axis you
can see three groups of things we tried
out so you have the baseline models on
the left then you have a bayesian model
in the middle and you have neural
network models on the right
and
so and then on the left you can already
see this id matching approach that i
mentioned before where you just kind of
match on this ein number and you get
like a f 0.5 score of 0.41
and
in general the precision is good um but
the recall is low with with these
matching id matching approaches so i
think and as i mentioned before for a
lot of the offers we don't have this ein
so of course we miss we miss a lot of
the offers with such a matching approach
um yeah then there's a second kind of
like we call the baseline approach
although it performed reasonably well as
a tf idf approach and there we just
calculated tf idf
feature vectors for each offer
[Music]
and then we clustered that also with k
nearest neighbors
and that performed reasonably well with
0.72 one of the big downsides of tf idf
here is that we that the vector
representation is is sparse right so
it's not like a nice efficient dense um
representation of your offer it's a it's
a huge
uh feature vector with like tens of
thousands of elements because our
dictionary is quite large um for for
this exercise because we have a lot of
brand names numbers and lots of unique
terms so
it's um it kind of explodes and it's
difficult to scale this
then another approach that especially
was was also by the way this is also a
cooperation with another product area at
idialo
from inventory so they they it's entire
team that's
focusing on this clustering topic and we
were just kind of sort of providing the
machine learning expertise
um and they they they are very kind of
comfortable in a spark environment and
they tried out a probabilistic um record
linkage um approach um called splink
there's also an open source library it's
um it's actually out of the british
ministry of justice
it's a really really nice package i can
definitely recommend it to try it out if
you're
if you have a record linkage um problem
um
so and and it performed also quite well
we had an f 0.5 score of 0.8
um
here one of the downsides was um
that in order to kind of like
have reasonable sort of like um training
times
um even on a pretty large spark cluster
you need to
maintain a pretty large set of rules and
especially like blocking rules and that
you basically reduce the search
search space
um so at the end of the day just for
this one category we ended up with a lot
of handcrafted rules and um yeah if we
wanted to scale this approach to other
categories this is like an exercise you
would always need to repeat so it it has
also its um its drawbacks there
yes and then we have the neural network
models and here we list all of the
transformer approaches and the first one
is this transformer not fine tuned with
0.58
and here we just took really
an out of the box
language model trained
on
on large amounts of data the boston will
go into more details in a little bit it
was kind of fine tuned for sentence
similarity um task so kind of fine-tuned
for our use case but if you take this
model straight from hugging phase um we
we got a score of around 0.58
um if you when we fine-tune this
this transformer model um with a triplet
network on our offer data
um we can we were able to increase this
to about 0.72
f 0.5 score
there's a little star here
we didn't do like a crazy amount of
hyper parameter tunings on this triplet
network approach um so probably we could
squeeze out some performance there but
it was um yeah it was still quite far
off from these other approaches so we
didn't we didn't invest too much time in
it
and then the second to last approach is
this arc margin network and um that's
like
that's like an architecture where um
yeah we just try to manipulate the
embeddings to an extent that they are
better separated in this embedding space
so if you're interested in that approach
i think it was
initially developed for face recognition
tasks
so quite often it goes under arc phase
and check it out it's it's quite
interesting and and it performed
reasonably well also for our use case
usually also when you see these com
these use cases on kaggle a lot of
people use that
so we had 0.82 there and then our for us
the best performing approach was these
transformer siamese networks and there
we um
train um yeah or fine-tune this
transformer in in the siamese fashion
um
and we sebastian will go into more
details in a second we reach a score of
0.84 there so that was that was the best
approach
so just to give you an overview of all
the of some of the most of the things we
tried out
um and and how they compare um
yes and i would just like um not sure
how many of you are familiar with with
the general concept um of of training
some of these models but i would like to
sort of like just highlight for this tf
idf and all the neural network
models it's basically the same concept
of how you fine tune this for your use
case and it's kind of like an embedding
based clustering so i would just briefly
like to give some details there so that
everyone is on board on on what we did
and i'm also going to link it to some of
the libraries that we used because
this is really a big takeaway of this
whole endeavor um that
this these amazing open source libraries
yeah just make such a project at least
for us possible so um
yeah we definitely want to bring home
that point so yeah again we start with
the offers here on the left so we have
three offers and then we would like to
um
to to to encode these offers somehow the
text attributes of these offers
and we use a machine learning model in
this case for that for the neural
networks approach for the tf-idf it's
just actually some counting logic it's
not even a machine learning model but
for neural networks we use we use a
neural network to encode these offers
and and the output or like one of the
intermediate layers that we use from
these neural networks these are these
embeddings which kind of like capture a
lot of information ideally of of that
offer
so we end up with
with some offers um which are basically
just vectors
for each of uh
sorry yeah some vectors for each of
these offers and then we cluster these
um vectors in
in this embedding space and
that's kind of like the whole idea of
the approach just conceptually
and
in our case the one that performed best
and
that's why we chose this title is that
for this machine learning model we use a
transformer and more specifically we use
the encoder part of a transformer
and the library we use for that is the
sentence bird library expert library and
and boston will also talk a bit more um
about that
and for the clustering we used um
k-nearest neighbor clustering and we
used the the the
face library um from meta formerly
facebook i'm not sure probably quite a
lot of people have used that before
and we'll also just share some lessons
learned with that library with you
yes that's it for my part and sebastian
will give you the
details hello everyone welcome from my
side i'm sebastian and i'm going to
share some learnings and the challenges
we had in this project and yeah one
finding was that siamese network with
transform models perform best in our
case and also for our data
and
uh yeah before i talk about siamese
networks i just want to quickly explain
the approach we have been following so
the approach is called transfer learning
and basically
the idea is that we train a model on
a source task using a large amount of
unlabeled text data and then we use that
pre-trained model again and find unit to
a similar problem or to a similar
task and therefore we we transfer the
knowledge from the first task and try to
get better on the second task
and usually the training objective for
the pre-training is the language
modeling task where we try to predict
the word in a given sentence
and in fine tuning for our case what we
want to achieve is that
we want to have
similar embeddings for similar offers
and
different embeddings for different
offers
and as our pre-trained model we use a
model developed by microsoft
it's called mpnet base and it's a
transformer encoder architecture with
over 100 million parameters it has been
drained on a lot of text 160 gigabyte of
text and over 35 days on a lot of gpus
and this model has a common
understanding about our language
and this model was then fine-tuned by
sentence transformer it's an open source
library and what i found out is that
these pre-trained models they're not
really suitable for sentence similarity
tasks and
that's why they extracted over one
billion sentence pairs and fine-tuned it
on that data set and additionally they
also extended it to other languages so
now these models support
over 100 languages
those models are available on
transformer model hub here so you can
download them and use that for your use
case
and what we did in the last step is that
we take this model from sentence
transformers and find unit again and why
did we do that well e-commerce data is
totally different from the data it was
used
in
which was used in pre-training and
fine-tuning and that's why we find unit
again to
improve the performance and also fit to
our use case
and the question is how did we do that
and yeah we used simus networks for fine
tuning
and
the siamese network takes
pairs of data samples as input so in our
case offers so you can see on the left
side we have two
offers of shoes with title and some
attribute values and these offers are
fed into our transformer encoder
those models those both models are
identical so they share the same
architecture they share the same weights
parameters and the reason is we don't
want to have different representation
for the same data that goes into those
models that's why they're identical
and the output
of our transformer encoder is now a
representation of our offer in form of a
vector so it's
called context vector and now we can
compare these vectors so
we can measure their similarity here you
can use a gradient distance in our case
we use cosine distance
we measure
the distance and
that will be the input for our loss
function and our
loss function is the contrastive loss
and when we minimize that loss it brings
similar offers together
and pushes
dissimilar offers more far away
we optimize our network we
change the weights in our
transformer and then on each iteration
we get better embeddings
and the interesting part is that
by fine-tuning this just
with this approach we could increase our
performance by 18 percentage points
before fine-tuning we had 58 and after
76 which was really nice
and here in this context we want to
mention the open source library sentence
transformer
the complete training was done with that
library it provides access to a bunch of
different language models all fine tuned
for sentence similarity
it's built on top of hacking face so you
easily can download every other model
you want to
use and just try it out and it also has
a lot of support for different other
languages and multilingual models
a lot of loss functions are implemented
you easily can exchange them and just
try out what works best for you
and
yeah this is the code we're actually
using so with a few lines of code we
were able to train
simus network
if you see the first two lines we just
download a pre-trained model we define
the data input and then with model fit
we can train a siamese network
another learning what we had is that
training pair generation makes really a
difference and also impacts our model
training
so when we train these networks we need
to have positive pairs and also negative
pairs because we need to tell our
network what means when offers are
similar and what means when offers are
not similar
and positive pairs are similar offers
and negative pairs are the similar
offers
and how do we create them so for
positive pairs it's actually
straightforward we have a training data
set we know
which offer belonged to which pro
product so what we can do is we just
pick two offers from the same product
and then that will be used as a positive
pair
for the negative pairs it's
one option what you can do is just
randomly select another offer from
another product
so in this case offer one and offer
three they are totally from different
products and can be used as negative
pairs
and here are lessons learned
if you select
random negative pairs then it might be
too easy for a model and they are
belonging to totally different
products and they don't share a lot of
similarity
such as
the model the color or
even a brand
and when we have this
random negative pairs then
the loss is really low and also it
doesn't contribute to our model training
and also the model convert quickly
converges and the performance is not
that great so the question is is there
any other ways of
creating better training examples and
yes there is so what you can do is you
can try to identify hard negative pairs
and heart of negative pairs are offers
which are really close by in the
embedding space
but
still belong to different products
so offer one and offer four they're
actually really close by but still they
are from two different products and
using this approach gave us some boost
of six percentage points
and here on the right side you can see
the strategy we have been following so
for each epoch we compute the embeddings
for all offers
and then
we use the embeddings to calculate the
average embedding for each product
cluster
and then this
embedding is used for
searching nearby offers
which are not in in the products but
still really close by and we use that
generate pairs and train it and for each
epoch we do that so
we will get more difficult negative
pairs and our model has a more harder
time to train and
yeah
drain better features
and yeah another learning is that
building product clusters can also be
challenging
and yeah product offers are now encoded
as vectors and we can be compared in
vector space so we apply the k and n
algorithm to create our products and
here on the left side you can see an
example
we have an orange data point
we search for their neighbors here in
this case k
is 10
and
then we found their neighbors the
closest
and now we apply a threshold so when the
distance is too large the offers get
removed and here in this example we have
five offers
which are over the threshold and we
remove them and the remaining offers
there from our clusters
and yeah we have a few challenges here
so our open catalog is really huge so we
need to scale to millions of vector
searches
and the search quality is also really
important we need to have high precision
high recall the recall is too low then
our clusters are really small and then
we cannot compare prices
and also search time is should be small
we don't want to wait like a week to
finish our job
and yeah we looked around and found fish
fish is open source and was built by
facebook research
and yeah it can scale to billions of
vectors
it has native gpu support
and
also a lot of out of the box
optimization strategies so you can do
vector compression you can
perform approximate nearest neighbor
where you not
scan the full index but only parts of it
and yeah it seemed to be perfect for our
use case we tried it out
in our first experiment we did a brute
force search so for every vector
we compared it to all other vectors in
in our index so it's not really
efficient but
we just tried it out as our first
experiment and we want to have high
precision and high recall and yeah here
on the left side you can see the
performance our index size was
around 25 gigabyte we stored 13 million
vectors in our index
we performed it on a tpu
and the time
it only took four hours a little bit
more than that and per vector we had a
search time of 1.2 milliseconds which
was already amazing for a brute force
search
and in the coming months we tried to
optimize that and try out a vector
compression and also the approximate
nearest neighbor search
and yeah here on the right you can see
the implementation we are using
again
only with a few lines of code we were
able to create an index store the
embedding and just do our
k n search
we also came across a few challenges in
our project and one of them is that when
we want to identify our final product
cluster we often find
overlapping clusters so here on the left
side we we did a k n search and for the
orange points
we found their neighbors and now we want
to create the clusters now and as you
can see they are overlapping now and the
question is how do you create these
clusters
and we looked into graph algorithms and
found a really nice algorithm called
label propagation algorithm and what
that algorithm does it it takes a random
walk through our k n graph and merges
areas which are densely connected so you
can see
the
result on the right side now we have two
separate clusters and we can use them as
product clusters
and this was also implemented by
spark library craft frames
and the last challenge i want to talk
about is that e-commerce data in channel
is really noisy and can be of poor data
quality we have short offer titles we
have missing attribute values and one
problem is that we have a hard time to
identify product variants
so here you can see two shoes they are
the same brand and the same model but
different colors
and if you only look at the title this
is what our model sees
then there's a lot of similarity there a
lot there's a lot of
common words
but only actually one word would decide
if they are in the same product cluster
or not and this is on the left side the
word
schwarz black
so sometimes this is really a problem
for a model to identify single tokens
which decides
if they are together in a product
cluster or not
and
yeah our next steps we are working to
bring the solution live
in the coming coming month and we also
started to work on images so we want to
include images
and to to improve our clustering result
and yeah i think that's it thanks for
listening and we're happy to answer
so we have a ton of questions so it's
great
first question is would it make sense to
integrate image data to
maybe in grayscale additionally to the
text data any downsides to that
yeah i fully agree with that we're
working on that we want to integrate
images why we started with text is
we didn't have the infrastructure to use
images right away so we are
it's more easier for us to access text
and their attributes and that's why we
started with that but images will solve
a lot of problems what we see with our
effects model
okay then
next question is um did you try
compression methods
in the tfidfk n approach on
non-transformer neural net approaches
like feed forward or
by lstm networks
now we haven't tried that one
second
um
i suppose
i think that meant to be idialo works
with german texts have you had no
problems getting pre-trained german
models
so actually our pre-trained model is
multi-lingual
so it doesn't matter if it's english or
german i think it supports over 100
languages
that's the mp net
and
sentence transformer actually extended
the model to different languages and
they used approach called multilingual
knowledge distillation
for that so it supports a lot of
different languages and yeah that's why
we didn't have a problem with that
okay have you tried using continuous
label values between
so basically having a fuzzy cluster i
believe that's what it's meant you know
we haven't tried it all okay
but it's yeah it's a good feedback and
you can think about that yeah
um can you tell us about how to obtain
ground truth data for the record linkage
problem
yeah that's not an easy question um
in our case uh yeah we're in the
fortunate situation that we have this
product catalog with millions of offers
already mapped to products so we can use
that as our training data um so and
that's that's that's that's one of the
things why we're able to do such a large
scale
um
approach here
um otherwise
yeah you just need to label data
which we're also starting to do
because we have a lot of
quality differences between offers and
especially the offers in the open
catalog have different characteristics
than the product catalog
so we are we're also hand labeling um or
starting to hand label open catalog
offers and it's actually not a trivial
task because like a
where do you start you know you can't
just have a human
pick all the offers from hundreds of
millions that belong to a cluster so
it's it's a challenge
okay um
i'm wondering if k n where the cluster
size has to be defined is the best
clustering approach can you share
experiences on db scan or other
strategies
so we didn't try out other
clustering approaches for the k n what
we just do is we choose
a big k so we
search for 300 neighbors and we select
then the offers based on a threshold
so
yeah
kate really doesn't mean
in our case a lot
we just use the threshold and then we
decide if they're in the cluster or
are removed
do you manually find hard negative pairs
manually yeah
not that i'm aware of no
okay
how do you react on you offers that come
in do you recalculate the clusters or do
you try to classify them in existing
classes
so if someone puts in a new article
yeah this is a really important question
for for productionizing the system so
in the end the
production pipeline has a step where we
when we retrain the model and we
generate new clusters that we calculate
the
um the mean embeddings of each cluster
and then we compare to previous mean
embeddings of existing clusters and then
we check whether there are already
existing clusters with very similar mean
embeddings
and so we keep cluster ids quite stable
through that which is an important part
and for the front end
um how noisy is your data
how many wrong labels do you typically
have
you're probably not better i personally
would say quite a quite noisy
so yeah as mentioned before
quite often you have
you have especially different variants
variants that belong to the same product
so for example shoes with different
colors but the same brand and model
um so that happens quite often which is
also one of the motivations where we
where we are starting to hand label and
some high quality data sets um yeah so
it's pretty noisy but
would it make sense to treat color words
differently to break the clusters better
apart
what kind of words
like
to treat color words differently i
believe to
have like the product description into
different categories
so what we did is that we use the color
and
we concentrate the title and the
attribute values and then also the
attribute names into it and this helps
our model to really identify okay now
colors coming and
that
also gave an improvement
so yeah other ways of
integrating it we haven't thought about
that
how did you build your fine tuning data
set
so for fine tuning we have the product
catalog
and with a lot of offers already
clustered
and we use that
for fine tuning so we know um this
product
has 150
offers and then we already have the
labels and
we can use that
and based on that we create our training
pairs
okay um
how often uh and how do you rebuild your
f
iass vector
what is the
face face
vector
so the index probably
yeah how often and how do you do it yeah
so currently we have a batch shop
running and this is done i think
i'm not sure once a week and then
we do the entire pipeline but i think
there's a lot of optimization possible
and
that will be
work in the coming coming months okay um
what challenges did you face when you
generalized your approach from sneakers
to everything else or have you do have
you done already
uh not yet okay so
that's uh also a big challenge we have
to
yeah
deal with in the next
or this year to try out to scale it to
different categories and and see
if we
really have to train it from um again uh
if we have to create a bigger data set
probably fashion categories are easier
for
for scale up and yeah we need to try it
out
then there's one request whether you
could share your slides i believe
there's a discord channel now so
yeah happy happy to share them there
cool um
would it be possible to recreate any of
your experiments on a google call up
instance
yeah i mean it's difficult because of
the data so we cannot really
make the actual data public i guess
but what i can recommend is there is a
kaggle competition shoppi i don't know
if some of you have heard it it's um s h
o double p double e
um and there it's it's it's almost in
exactly the same setting so it's around
clustering offers um and they they
provide text and image data
and we use that
competition heavily for inspiration and
there are lots of really great notebooks
there so
check that out and you can you can see
very very similar approaches there
okay how did you combine the different
stack at a different
i don't know what it means but anyways
um how did you combine the difference
text features into one embedding i
believe it's probably different text
features
just
concatenate
right yeah
so we have title and then we have the
attribute name attribute value attribute
name attribute value
and
for the show category we have a lot of
attributes but we found out that
actually three attributes
contribute to a performance
boost and that's why
we have color we have product type as
information and the third one was
target group
how did you decide the right metric for
your task
yeah i mean that's partly also business
driven i think
so it's it's it was important for them
to
that we
generate precise clusters more than have
complete clusters so it's better to
leave an offer out than putting wrong
offers into the cluster
and yeah so it was pretty a natural
choice to go for an f score with a
higher weighting on precision really
so i think precision recoil lends itself
quite well to um
to clustering
so yeah that's kind of how it how it
came about
um do you think there
would be a chance of doing this manually
your work you know do you think there's
a competition
uh where you would imagine like a strong
process
which new products have to go through
such that you don't need to do those
things
i mean the thing is idialo is doing it
manually right so we have a lot of
people that that work on creating the
product catalog and and and working on
the mapping logic of offers to the
product catalog so we are
humans create our products at the moment
and
we know it's very very labor intensive
and we cannot keep up in a lot of
categories like fashion or diy
where there are a lot of new products
on a regular basis so that's why the
human approach doesn't really scale and
that's why we are investigating this
automated approach
one question based on this one just for
us
okay what is the reaction of the people
that do this manually to know that
they're people kind of replacing their
jobs
okay i i need to repeat what is the
reaction of the other people in the
company that do this manually
yeah i think the keyboard is replacing
because it's not about replacing um so
that's why it's a very positive kind of
ad or like environment and it's more
about enabling and and giving new
tooling that
basically
enable them to create more products
because there will always be a human in
the loop
so it's
it's very positive in that sense
seems like a lot of info goes missing
with the cosine distance step did you
manage trying to feed the context
vectors directly to the contract to the
constructive loss
for me personally that
does not make sense
um
but maybe for you
yeah i mean the contrastive loss is
you need to
input
distance value
into
formulation that's why
think
it's not possible
you could use other distances
but yeah you need some sort of metric to
put into the loss function
next one did you try starting with your
5 million data points and not a
pre-trained model
if yes how much worse was it
yeah i think we mentioned that where we
didn't fine tune on our data
and it was around 0.58
[Music]
so let me show this slide here
um so this would be
difficult so here we go
this would be this um basically just
taking an out-of-the-box transformer not
fine-tuned on idealo data and using it
for clustering you get 0.58
with fine-tuning we got 0.84 so i think
it was
yeah
sorry misunderstood um
i i think we haven't done that no we
haven't done that
but i think the big benefit of this
transfer learning is that you create
language language model on unlabeled
text and then use the knowledge from
there so yeah i mean we could
yeah i think it's a very fair point we
saw that in other
classification models that we do on on
offer text data that
usually these language models do not
outperform more vanilla approaches like
tf idf
so that would be in a valid experiment
we could try out
okay then thank you so much for
answering all the questions